okay so I'm gonna try something a little
different here cuz every time I do a
bummer view I always have like a little
sentence that says what I've really
thought of the movie and a lot people
are saying what do you mean by that is
there more to it or way real thoughts so
would that be bummer view now I'm just
gonna do my own review under it if you
want to know what I've really thought um
so first one is Thor I literally just
got back from watching it and pricey I
just got done doing the bum review too
and honestly just after leaving it I I
liked it I thought it was a lot of fun I
haven't read the comics so I don't know
how faithful it is I mean it certainly
looks like Thor I mean he's got the red
cape you've got the helmet though he
doesn't wear the helmet much which is
probably a good thing um but actually
surprisingly it didn't look that bad on
him so maybe that maybe he should have
worn it a little more um but for me when
I heard they're making a Thor movie I
was just like what the wings and they
have a come on you can't you can't make
that you know you can't do that and not
laugh at it but then the wafer kenneth
branagh was gonna direct i thought okay
this can work this can be interesting
cuz everything he does is so big and
over-the-top and even when it fails it's
so big and it's it's so entertaining um
you know Mary Shelley's Frankenstein is
a good example it's a terrible movie but
it's just so huge and so massive and and
he just goes balls out and this film
it's the same thing if you were to look
at anything pretty much anything in this
movie individually a set a costume
anything just on its own you would
probably laugh at it but because he
creates this world and just goes all out
I mean just throws a ton of money at
this gap bo Welch as the production
designer just creates this incredible
world um and just these great design the
costume design is unbelievable it really
is certain like watching an opera sort
of a modern-day opera okay and they get
really really creative with it so I
really like that aspect a lot the look
of the film in a sense that I don't say
it's a proud because it's not a problem
but about
20 minutes in it goes into the
fish-out-of-water story and it works and
nothing it doesn't work but it's sort of
like up you're not gonna top the opening
you're not gonna tie with up I think
it's like the first ten minutes with
this I think it's like the first 20 um
the worlds they create are so cool and
so awesome that when you get to the
middle of the desert it's like okay and
we know this stick but it's done well
and I want to emphasize that because a
lot of these fish-out-of-water stories
they usually do you know the
fish-out-of-water is all grump and he
hates everything if he questions
everything he's angry they can't
understand and the person that has to
take care of him or her usually it's a
woman you know she gets angry what's
wrong with you you're crazy and me first
whatever reason sticks around with him
uh in this it's it's done much better
because you have Thor he is a little bit
of a barbarian like you'll finish your
drink he says I want more he throws it
on the ground and Natalie Portman would
say you don't do that it's like why
Jesse don't he goes okay and he actually
listens and they actually like learning
from each other they don't get really
angry which you could argue maybe is a
little unrealistic but because we've
seen this so many times in movies I
think it's welcomed that you want to see
these people actually enjoy learning and
enjoy finding out about the other so
it's not okay and the comedy is actually
pretty good um Natalie Portman is
surprisingly pretty decent do I
I don't hate Natalie Portman or anything
I usually just find ur acting very you
know there's Natalie Portman there's you
wasn't you know just nothing much to it
but I think ever since Black Swan it's
like now she took this performance that
it's just or your standard you know
we're just the normal person showing him
around performance actually did make it
sort of she's very optimistic and she's
very energetic and you know wants to
find out more and said it's she's she's
very likable and Thor is very likable
and it works because he's cocky and he's
and you know he wants to rush into
things but he's not a total idiot either
you understand where he's coming from
and you do sort of
leave the the change he goes through and
the actors great actor who plays them is
very believable all the actors are
actually very very believable nobody was
like okay I'm a bind day you buy it
so that's very good um everything in
this movie it is very large and very big
because of that it sort of suffers from
like the lore of the Rings matrix
principles where there's about a
bajillion plot points that don't make
sense there's a scene where they freeze
this guy I think in the last third of
the movie and of course anyone would
just kill him after that you can see the
ice monster there's ice monsters in this
it it's better that sounds and you see
the ice monsters freeze these people and
smashing that's like why didn't they
just do with this guy cuz obviously he's
gonna escape there's this Rainbow Bridge
you know that's sort of it's it's magic
and technological again I think that's
the comics it's like a mix of both and
it like at the end something happens to
it without giving away too much and oh
no what are we gonna do and of course
something build another one you made it
before and there's this one pouring
where Thor's versus hammer down and like
all the land crumbles and mountains come
coming to have why hasn't he done that a
bajillion times before you know so
there's there's a lot of those it's
magic bitch moments where are you Joe
it's magical that's it so if you're
gonna nitpick it's not good movie friend
a Pickers so I'll say that out there a
you say in terms of comics I don't know
how well followed it either but for what
it is just sort of a fun big comic book
movie action movie yeah I thought it was
pretty decent I would have liked at the
end and there's a lot of build up the
first 20 minutes it's like the best part
of the movie and there's a lot of build
up for great big things the climax I
didn't feel like much was at risk and uh
yeah without giving away too much
there's people that are that Thor wants
to save and you sir
go well okay yeah but that I'm not that
invested in these people and they've
given us lots of reason not to be
invested in these people and he's just
are doing it because it's the right
thing well great but it's not it's not a
huge climax it's not I get when he gets
the hammer back and he flies up there he
spins around the clouds you're expecting
a really big cool client you know a
climax of the gods and it's okay
it's decent it's a decent climax and of
course they have to save room for the
sequels whatever the Avengers and stuff
like that so uh that was it's not
terrible it's just not as big as you're
sort of hoping it's gonna be but for
what it is it was I'm glad they got kin
to Branagh cuz I think he's the only one
that could make this movie work it's
it's a very silly movie to bring to life
and he did a good job and I was shocked
at how much I was buying into this and
having fun with it so um yeah overall I
liked it it's definitely you know not
perfect but I had a really good time I
think people who go to see this movie
will probably like what they see
I think they'll serve feel like what I
did almost like with the Iron Man movies
it they want a bigger resolution they
want a bigger climax and you know it's
it's okay and I think when they see the
trailer he's like I want something much
bigger at the end and they're not quite
gonna get it but but there's the promise
of more which I know you know anyone
that likes comic books likes to be
continued you know and there's our
movies are very good at that so yeah so
there it is that's my thoughts I'm Thor
and yeah I think with every bump with
you now I'm just always gonna have a
review on the bottom just saying what I
really thought as well so that's about
it and I'll see you next week